thank you
[Music]
action and welcome back to a very
special careful boys where we are indeed
very careful boys and we are currently
off the Record and today we are talking
about
do you guys remember the first time that
you use a swear word nope
but I do remember
loving the say words I'm not supposed to
my mom has a tape recording of me for
about 40 minutes straight singing about
poop pee poop Kaka vomit fart whatever
as a kid and that was the best [__] ever
so that's exactly what this prompt is
about
so you you do remember yeah yeah because
I thought that word were like the actual
ones because you know it's like hey you
pee pee head yeah exactly I [__] said
when were you saying some [__] that
you're you knew like you [__] this could
be [__] crazy if I say around my
folks it could be I gotta be careful
here you know what though I never got in
trouble for saying it okay because even
if they heard you they I mean she kept
the tape she thought it was hilarious oh
like a lot of the stuff
that I was not supposed to do outside
somehow she found a way to like teach me
it didn't work but she she taught me
that it was wrong and I knew it was
wrong
but I didn't do it I taught you the
words period like who taught you then
you're it somewhere from school from
France
you don't know what they meant but you
knew it was bad and you used it
oh yeah I'm gonna open the prompt up too
to racial episode so Anthony can jump in
I remember my first uh racial episode
I'm just kidding no I remember my first
time I was talking some [__] I got in
trouble I was in second grade
and I remember I heard a kid say suck my
dick right oh yeah in second grade
second grade [__] wow and um it's
Advanced that's really advancing and
then he was he was doing this
he was doing that do you think his
parents like he's so Advanced he's
already doing something he's doing the
DX yeah
um and then I just started copying them
all right and I remember people started
laughing so I just kept doing it and at
the time
I remember the fact that I remember this
is pretty interesting I remember I had a
fruit roll up
that I that I let hang all the way down
it was like really long and I was like
out of my mouth and I just kept doing it
it's pretty good though and I remember
it was it was Mrs uh Underwood's class
in second grade and then um I was making
too much of a scene and then someone
told on me and then um didn't take long
I meant no did it and then my guidance
counselor uh Mr Smith he nabbed me and
he had a talk with me and said hey you
can't be using this kind of language
like where did you learn this from and I
was like I heard Michael say it blah
blah blah blah blah and then I just was
ever since then I just had a little
potty mouth dude and I just was like my
dick and I was doing that I remember
huh you know what that meant you know
what that meant I I assume to this day
with me nope I have no idea I was hoping
you guys would tell me wow yeah he
doesn't know I was hoping to have my
first experience yeah so they didn't
they told you just not to say it but you
didn't actually get in trouble huh no
well they'd uh my mom I think my mom had
to come pick me up oh damn that is
trouble I got in trouble for that dude
but it was more kind of like what were
you doing like where'd you learn that
from like it's kind of innocent though
yeah it was just like they didn't really
get that mad at me and it wasn't until I
was in like fourth or fifth grade where
I got like really in trouble dude at
least it wasn't your stepmom because you
probably would have tried to show you oh
wow jeez it's already that kind of sick
that's just the real world there was um
the first time I saw a cuss word at all
or learned about one I remember now it
was our neighbor when I was this was
like 1989 and in Downey it was still a
lot of like white people that lived
there and then we had this white family
next to us and they had like a teenage
dude that was like you know like a bad
white kid and uh he used to pick up the
dog [__] in his yard and toss it over
the wall so we would have this random
dog [__] in our yard before you learned
the dog [__] trick huh yeah that's right
that was the evolution yeah
he um so they might I remember my dad
went over there and he told his mom that
like oh your son's been like throwing
dog [__] over the wall like tell him
stop doing that and she was like okay
that's fine and then like
um later on that day we went out of the
house to go to the car because we were
going somewhere and they had taken like
chalk and they wrote a giant [__] you on
the street in the direction of our house
what they did it toward you too yeah and
then continued throwing dog [__] they
never stopped yeah my my I remember my
parents like saying like oh like me and
my sister read it out loud we're like
[__] you what's that and then my my dad
and my mom were like oh that's something
you should never say and then that's
where like literally like I learned oh
that's the worst thing you can say to
someone yeah and then my dad didn't know
what [__] was no I didn't know what
it was me neither I just remember my dad
said that like oh they're they're really
bad and they're bullying us so never use
that to someone else I feel like kids
used all those words it didn't know what
they meant yeah
yeah there's I mean I didn't learn for a
long time with that man I just knew it
was like bad it's a very powerful word
yeah they moved away though and they and
they left their cats and they all died
oh goodness they abandoned like a ton of
cats there was like a bunch of cats in
the neighborhood and they all like just
like died they're all sick they're dog
people so they're so [__] up wow they
became murders later they could have was
it like a hoarder house with cars parked
on their lawn yeah kind of yeah yeah
back in the day Donnie had a lot of
people like that yeah a lot of like yard
peoples yeah yeah it wasn't like a nice
city and then like white flight happened
and everyone was Mexican and Asian in
the neighborhood now
my flight happened so I vividly remember
the two instances one I've already
shared on here before I'll show it again
uh I got in trouble both times I don't
remember exactly where I learned it I
was at my Grandpa's funeral in Hawaii
somewhere in like 1996 or something like
that
and I somehow learned the term [__]
[__] so go on somehow I don't know it's
a good one but you know when you learn
it in your mind as a kid you're like
when do I get to use it though you know
what I'm saying yeah you know not to but
you're just like whatever's on the
trigger dude yeah that's a good one all
my cousins right we're like upstairs in
like my my Grandpa's old apartment and
then all my cousins like start tickling
me and stuff and they like hold me down
you know what like [__] different
cousins aren't holding you down and
stuff you know like tickling you have
nowhere to go so I remember just like
kicking and flooding and then I was like
you [__] [__] and everybody let go
of this I was a kid everybody let go at
the same time
uh basically the same age a lot of big
moves dude and then immediately one of
my cousins she like just runs downstairs
she is a [__] dish anyway what a narc
yeah runs downstairs
you know like tells on me and [__] like
that oh he got told on dang and then
straight up from there too many raps my
family yeah my dad is like the most
physically like you up out of all the
aunties and uncles anyway so I was I was
in for it and they literally did all
that [__] that you see in like [__]
Christmas stories they took me into the
restroom they were slapping me up and
took a bar of soap shoved it in my mouth
oh oh my God that's not well I mean I
probably deserved it were you like this
with the bar soap that's cultural
appropriation yeah yeah were you do you
have a dove bar in there yes it's not a
Vietnamese style you can see and it's
funny because there's evidence of this
you could see in the giant family photo
that happened right after it all the
aunties uncles and cousins and I'm the
only one who's fully like cry against
you bro you gotta get that picture they
captured it [__] [__]
so true like back in the day it's like
you get your ass handed to you and
you're crying and the The Show Goes On
like everyone's still like they let it
go they have a lot of those where I'm
crying in a group picture I remember
every single party someone was getting
[__] spanked or in trouble yeah it
has to happen yeah yeah and then the
second second one I mentioned the story
before but it's uh it's a good lesson
for all the children out there I learned
again I heard the term uh stupid gaffit
but not gaffit right and then I didn't
know you know like when I was gonna use
it or anything like that and I just
remember pocket I remember I was in like
third or fourth grade or something like
that we're playing during recess and
remember when the school bell rings
everybody's supposed to freeze right
right right what I was about to use this
time I used this term I was like
somebody said something I don't remember
what they said maybe they called me like
whatever and then I was like you're
stupid and I said it and the bell rang
so I froze and then the guys looking at
me his little black kid and he's like
what'd you say right he starts walking
towards me but I'm like in my mind I'm
like you can't move you can't move
freeze and I just didn't do any because
I was like I'm following the rules I
gotta freeze he came over and he [__]
threw me down on the floor and I was all
crying as a kid what and he didn't get
in trouble because no none of the
[__] safeties were doing their
patrolling job the right way oh [__]
it's mine
I remember it after that I was like I
probably shouldn't throw that term
around yeah that's a well that's pretty
crazy that he got that mad
well I mean I probably shouldn't be
calling somebody a stupid Gadget you
know what I mean but I remember in the
in the early days of cuss words no one
will stand our practice because
everyone's practicing using them all the
time yeah everybody called each other
gay yeah yeah yeah yeah I didn't even
know it meant a homosexual relationship
I hope at some point I actually called a
gay guy yeah I doubt it did
I didn't even know that yeah we just
thought it meant like stupid back in the
day I just thought it meant girly I
definitely got called Gay more
infinitely more I was called Gay all the
time
and then later on you learn what what
the real meaning is in your life whoa I
didn't know boys kiss boys like that he
learned in like sixth grade science
class we learned gay like in actual
class and as soon as like everyone
learned what it was they all pointed at
me
every single one of them
Savage and then and then uh teacher
teacher is Ryan gay then it's funny
because like that's a good idea because
everyone's like it's a good grouping why
did they all think you were gay were you
flamboyant today's video is brought to
you by Warby Parker okay so sometimes
you're on a website looking and shopping
for eyewear and you're like man this
stuff looks so cool but I don't know if
it's gonna look good on me so pass how
many of you guys do that at home because
for me there's been so many times when
I've bought glasses it came in and I'm
looking at it I put it on and for some
reason it just does not fit but thank
goodness we got Warby Parker baby yeah
because they got the home try on kit
where you can pick five of the glasses
you can try it on and then you can send
back the ones that you don't want and
what I like about Warby Parker is
sometimes you're you know a lot of times
you're buying stuff for a special event
someone's wedding you're gonna go over
here and and it's too late if you get
the glasses and it doesn't fit your
outfit or your needs oh yeah so with
Warby Parker you deal with sunglasses
eyeglasses they got all kinds even
contact lenses for Eye Care kit and they
even have in-person retail stores too
all right so like I was saying Warby
Parker offers you everything you need
for happier eyes eyeglasses sunglasses
contact lenses and even eye exams and
you can shop with them online or in
stores too and glasses start at 95 bucks
including prescription lenses so try the
Warby Parker's free home try on program
order five pairs of glasses to try on at
home for free there's no obligation to
buy ships free and even includes a
prepaid shipping label so try five pairs
of glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com off the Record no it's
just like it was just fun to roast each
other and then they just got me that day
for you they just literally what you do
is like oh that's what that means so
then that makes Ryan like
I was like I got Association at that
time yeah
I remember
um a lot of kids used words that they
didn't know what it was like I remember
one time
um the these kids were like play
fighting right and then they're like hey
you're a molester and I'm like Lester
those are pretty funny man dude oh he's
a big kid and then um if a if a big
adult or kid is beating you up that's a
molester so then I was like oh he goes
yeah someone who beats up kids is a
molester right so I was playing with my
cousin
um and my cousin at the time he's like
he's he's like 15 years older than me
right so like [__] wrestling and all
that stuff and then he gets me down and
I'm all like monastery
it works that's scary dude oh yeah no
way family was like what the [__] and
then they're like and then I was like I
got up and I'm like molester molester
like that right you're a [__] you're
you're you beat up kids and he goes
that's not what it means and then he was
so scared and I was like I was like did
I do something wrong and then he's like
no that means um they touch your
privates and stuff like that and then
like oh he will he just [__] my face
like that's like when he's messing with
your head right
dude God people molesters underrated
dude that's underrated but if you're a
kid and you don't know the gravity of
that you're just tossing it around
he was like I'm not gonna play with you
anymore if you say that
molester you're a little kickoff oh
that's crazy can you imagine you're like
playing with your little nephew [__]
wrestling him around and [__] and he
goes hey molester and I'm like what the
[__] bro drop a kid wild yeah dude yeah
no thank you right oh I do heavy messing
yeah so I mean I've been I work I used a
lot of words like that dude so um I
didn't really know what the N word was
because I heard it in rap I heard it and
everyone at school
um nipples okay nice no but like all the
way up until I don't know like
third or fourth grade you know everybody
everybody Asian kids black kids
everybody said it in Gardena yeah it was
uh it was 186th Street Elementary School
you know that's the name of the school
she sounds like a straight-up game
dude what the [__] yeah I went to
Rolling 60s Academy
that's when elementary schools like
don't wear these colors yeah
and then we never used it in a in a way
where it was like
Fu like it's a bad word it was like it
was always loud that's my friend in the
homey way yeah yeah yeah
well yeah it's true because you don't
see it used in the bad way as a kid
right yeah and then I was singing it
with my friend right
we were in the we were there was a
system over and over again yeah no we
were singing a song together the lyrics
yeah and then he was black you know so
so I didn't see anything wrong with it
but I didn't know it was a black I
didn't know it was about race and then
we get up to the uh up in front of the
snack line I'm singing the song with
them and then the snack lady was like
Joseph and I'm like oh she's black
no she was Asian and then she goes I
can't believe what you're saying and I'm
like what what and then I'm like what
did I do did I say stupid like what did
I say like I was like so confused and
she goes go back to the line and think
about what you just did and then so I
was at the back of the line like [__]
shivering and I'm like all I want is a
[__] Twinkie and a [__] orange
juice and I don't know what I did right
so I get back she goes are you ready to
apologize
and I'm like what he goes you know what
you said and she wouldn't repeat the
word right that's cool the lunch lady
cared to discipline you on that though
that's that's funny though the idea of
like him yeah yeah him and his black
friends saying it but she can't
discipline the book yeah that word is
not for you Joe but I didn't even know
it was a bad word and then so so she
tells me like you know what that means
and I'm like I don't know and she goes
that's a a mean way that they used to
say to Slaves so you shouldn't use that
word and all that and my mind just went
I was like what and you probably learned
more from the lunch lady than from the
teachers there huh oh yeah that's that's
cool yeah I didn't know I took the time
to tell you that but dude back then like
I could have got you killed you're in
elementary school you're listening to
Tupac Biggie you're listening to NWA
you're listening to Ice Cube you're
listening to Jackie Chan in rush hour my
parents are immigrants they don't speak
English so they didn't they didn't say
you can't listen to this music oh yeah
because hip-hop to them they could they
knew that rock is is like the devil yeah
Rock was the thing that was bad yeah and
I hear you listen to [__] electric
guitar so I was like okay well I listen
to Eric Clapton yeah I listen to hip-hop
I can listen to hip-hop fine I'm playing
hip-hop all day they can't they don't
understand what the lyrics are right and
what you're like second third fourth
grade you don't know what you know so
that that was my whole shock of like oh
[__] that's what it meant yeah yeah
and I kept using it until High School
yeah because all my friends did and then
and then I use it I used it yesterday
he's at the grocery store yesterday dang
until I had a bigger vocabulary to
express friendship do you remember that
like uh one time the the pastor at in
high school had this one like sermon and
it was like
what do you guys think is the worst cuss
word of them all and everyone was like
[__] [__] like it was like they got
permission yeah he's like no the worst
cuss word of all is God damn
and we were like ah really that's a week
it was like because everything else is
like I guess he's saying that all other
cuss words are just cultural constructs
people make up linguistically but then
saying God damn actually traces back to
blaspheming against the Lord so you're
not gonna go to heaven yeah so you can
say [__] is what you want yeah you just
kind of say God damn I thought that was
interesting because then he was very
like liberal on like explaining that and
we were all going through all the
customers if you didn't care just
raising your hands yeah I wasn't allowed
to say
um God like God like God's name in vain
right so you're not supposed to be like
oh God yeah that's right you can't say
oh my God yeah you're saying it in a way
that's negative so then what what they
said you should do is when someone says
that word you go shh so it turns into
gosh
oh so it's like oh God yo
shh and it's gosh
over here my mother wouldn't let you you
do it I could say a lot of things I
could say shut up but that was pretty
bad yeah but shut up was a pretty bad if
I said God damn it was over my mother
wouldn't mind it yeah guys are pretty
gosh darn I don't remember the context
but I remember the word because I'm a
[__] no is [__] damn yeah I'm
trying to I'm sitting here trying to L
Jackson
trying to think about the context I
think it was just something that I had
heard and then we just kind of [__] up
it's so bad yeah definitely
um but yeah I don't know I I know that
it was [__] for some reason
though that was your first cuss word
that was my first [__]
[__] I think it was one of those
situations where it was just like
something stupid happened you stepped
your toe yeah something's that stupid
and I was just like [__] and
there's like Colleen
don't say that I was like sure what did
they say when I used the word [__] for
the first time I don't even know what
I'm saying
what it meant I just thought it was
[__] hilarious the man kept saying it
and so my uncle like who came to help us
move because we lived in Fairfax
Virginia and like it was time to move to
San Diego and then my uncle's like I'll
help you guys move so then they get a
U-Haul and then my uncle comes and my my
mom like we they take the van but then
I'm like the first born son so I get to
go in the U-Haul with my uncle and my
dad and then the in the U-Haul my uncle
my dad my uncle Clan's just going like
[__] goddamn piece of [__]
[__] and all [__] damn and I was
like this is so cool because like my
dad's not like going like oh like all
the [__] that he does when I'm watching
the movie or whatever yeah he was
treating me like I'm a man yeah now you
could talk like the adults or this is
cool but I couldn't do it yet with
around them but I I was absorbing the
[__] out of it in the wrongest way but I
was like oh man it's so cool that my
dad's not stopping me from hearing this
[__] because normally he did that
and I was like and then I got my sister
and then and I was like I was like hey
Jen I was like
hey [__] this [__] yeah we don't get to
see our friends anymore [__] this [__]
and then my sister like had the
permission now to do it too because I
was doing that so you weren't cussing
but now you two siblings secretly
started cussing she's like yeah [__]
this [__]
how old were you guys like we're like
I'm like nine years old and she is like
she's like 11. yeah and then yeah so
we're both like giving each other
permission it's a cool with me and her
and we're very close but like we used to
have like um a partition on our wall
like through like the uh electrical
outlets where I could hear her and she'd
hear me when the doors were closed so we
could talk to each other through the
wall oh cool how romantic hey Jen [__]
this [__] show me those titties
but like [__] this [__] right so like
and so that kind of became like the this
like thing we had with each other where
like we were allowing each other to say
swear words but then we knew to clean it
up when the folks were around you guys
are each other safe space yeah yeah yeah
those are like secret sibling packs
handshake like yeah secret romance we've
always had each other's back since then
that's cool yeah but then she married
again this is not me
I just I dread the thought of someone
finding this as their first video just
to having no contact with the eyes white
guy
punch sister that makes sense
it's always been the bit